how're you doing today sir I'm good how
you doing good so I'm gonna start by
saying congrats on your first feature
yeah I know you made like a TV movie but
this is like the first you know bit it
is yeah yeah um so I have to ask you
what was it how long were you trying to
make a feature do you know what I mean
like it was one of these things who you
went in on a ton of projects and you
finally got the keys to this Ferrari
yeah no I mean no I mean you know I've
never I've never actively chased a
feature film you know for me it's all
about the script it's all about the
story it's all about why we tell in this
story now if that's a small little you
know half-hour TV show or if that's a
you know massive great blockbuster movie
like this then that's cool I don't have
a sort of burning didn't have a bit of
burning desire to make a movie
I just I'm all I'm interested in is
telling you know intercooled purposeful
inspiring stories talk a little bit
about going in to meet for this because
obviously you must have pitched on this
I'm sure there was other people that
maybe pitched as well I'll talk a little
bit about going into that room and and
trying to tell the studio your take on
the material and how nervous were you
well it went the other way actually
really yeah yeah and actually you know
in truth you know I met with the
president of Lionsgate in can about but
I think it was three three years ago and
he'd just seen a show a TV show that I
did called peaky blinders and which he
liked and so he actually was you know
pitching it to me yeah and saying you
know if you want to do a Robin Hood film
and I was like you know why does the
world need another Robin Hood film so
initially I was like pretty reluctant to
do it because I hadn't really understood
what my view of Robin Hood was just the
films I'd seen I didn't understand what
Robin Hood was or and I didn't realize
who this guy was and what the
opportunities of retail in this story
were so you know it was um yeah there
wasn't so it wasn't it was more just
like you know and then we kind of talked
and talked and actually sort of you know
talked more and realized that I actually
hang on that's a really really cool
version of this film waiting to be told
so one of the things I really like about
this is that in like a lot of the other
versions of Robin Hood the sheriff's
always after Marian like there's you
flip a lot of stuff on its head talked a
little about that aspect of it that this
is not like a Robin Hood you've seen
before
that's that was the whole purpose I mean
listen there being some great Robin Hood
films I wasn't interested in adding to
that legacy I wanted to yeah and this
Robin Hood story it's been told over 600
years there are hundreds and thousands
of variations of this movie of this
story I mean and it's a myth that
doesn't he never even existed you know
so it's like to me it was like taking
that myth taking that metaphor and
picking it up and you know dumping it
kicking and screaming into the 21st
century and making this kind of very
very modern very visceral very kind of
you know resonant version of it that
would hopefully kind of entertain like
our stuff but also what people would
watch it and go oh hang on that's that's
really interesting because I'm
recognizing in the sheriff you know a
political leader I'm recognizing in the
church the same kind of oppression that
goes on in the church now I'm
recognizing that that war over there you
know it's as Japanese as unjust as
insane as that wars being fought in the
Middle East or whatever you know there's
a lot in there that kind of resonates
for a 21st century audience so you know
that's what our my ambition was was to
was to was to make a very very different
version of it you know there's no in my
mind you know what's the purpose in
making a sort of yeah a nice little
pretty kind of gold frame you know some
fairy tale that was set six hundred
years ago in a small town in not in the
north of England you know fun to watch
but doesn't affect me in my life doesn't
affect you and your load it's not going
to resonate it's not going to make you
think oh hang on it's not gonna make you
think you're just go watch it enjoy it
or but it's not gonna have any
reflection on how you're living or the
choices you're make you know what you're
what you're surrounded by and what's
going on in society Nottingham is also
radically different than any version
we've seen before
it's a massive City and it really looks
like the center of like the country talk
about designing the city and because
it's completely different everything you
say is exactly what we intended listen I
mean this film is historically insane it
makes no is no historical accuracy in
the film whatsoever sure yeah it's not
meant to the film you know Nottingham
never ever looked like that and never
would have looked like that clothes
they're wearing clearly and not the
clothes they're wearing in the middie
it's not meant to be a history lesson
you know but you know for me I want to
tell a big big story now if you've got a
guy
heeeh cause in a small revolution in a
small town in the north of England so
what so let's turn not in him into this
thrive in kind of metropolis the
industrial capital of England the
religious capital of being and the
political capital of England so that
therefore if a revolution starts there
that's gonna have you know it's big
scale so it's really all about making
the film feel bigger and feel more
modern
I would I would imagine you did test
screenings or early friends-and-family
screenings what did you learn from those
screenings that impacted the finished
film what was really interesting about
it is that you know is that when you're
doing a screening of a film nobody's got
nobody's had nobody's seen any press
nobody's seen any print and already seen
any trailers so people come into a Robin
Hood film and they kind of go you know
expecting you know expecting the
traditional Robin Hood film so it was
interested in watching people kind of
recalibrate in in the cinema and kind of
go go you know and often people would
take a while to kind of I think what's
happening now what we're seeing now is
that because there's been all you know
all the trailers have come out and been
materials people have seen okay this is
not Men in Tights you know they're
already they're already prepared for for
how different and how extreme this film
is sure I'm always curious about deleted
scenes what didn't make the finished cut
did you have a lot or was it just like a
few no there's a lot you know I mean we
there's a lot that we wanted to get in
this film you know that's that's the
body relationship between John and Robin
that's their the love story but the love
triangle between you know between Jamie
Dornan scary to effuse character in town
and Edgerton there's the political
themes the religious stuff and it was a
lot you know and and the film was
creaking under the weight of all of that
and so you know you know we had to do a
bit of balance and you have to kind of
sacrifice a few of your babies to sort
of make to make the whole thing stand up
so there's some stuff that didn't make
it you know and there's some arcs that
are you know that we didn't you know
paint as you know spend as much time on
as we might or with other arcs you know
so but that's the you know when you're
making a big big movie like this that's
you know you want it to appeal to a
broad abroad audience your that's the
that's the juggle you know there are
there are going to be sacrifices and
there are going to be things that you
know stories that you really want to
tell but or somebody really wants to
tell but you realize that actually it's
it's affecting you know affecting sort
of the bigger picture
sure I mean I've spoken to many
filmmaker
and they have a 3-hour cut what ends up
in theaters is 220 you know it's just
the nature of the beast
yeah you know I know I'm really I was
always really really committed to it
being subhead you know minutes
you know III you know I'm very
passionate about stories being told you
know short and fast it wasn't so much
about the length you know III never
wanted the film to be two and a half
hours long you know because you know I I
just don't like this kind of movies you
know it was more just about your choices
which part you know which little paths
are you going down before I run the time
with you I'm very curious and excited
for His Dark Materials yeah I believe
you're working on that I am yeah we're
in the middle of our we're in the middle
of shooting and editing at the same time
it's a it's a really really exciting
project BBC HBO they're going for a big
time and what's exciting about it it's
they're giving it the space you know
we're spending eight hours on just the
first book for the first season and then
the second season will be the second
book units kind stuff so it's you know
it's it we're really hope you know we've
got the the space there to tell the
story the same kind of depth and magic
that Philip Pullman told it in the first
place
sure for people that aren't familiar
what was it about and I gotta go but
what was it about that book in the
material that said I want to do this
it's you know it's for me it's the whole
Magisterium story in there it's kind of
like you know any it's innocent they're
not that they're out there you know
there are similarities between this and
Robin Hood you know any book or any
piece of storytelling that challenges
the status quo that challenges it
challenges the structure and the ideals
and the beliefs that we've created and
allowed and and and and you know
furnished in society anything that come
and comes in and goes hang on you know
is is you know it is that true and
actually is the church the the
organization of me immoral you know
enjoy me anything that comes in and kind
battles the cage and kind of asks us you
know the bigger questions I get excited
by thank you so much Congrats on the
movie good luck with all the interviews
you